and here's a couple of young men who are
obviously getting lonely this guy took
his own take on relationship advice
career I need a little bit of advice
it's not relationship advice like you
usually do I need some career advice I'm
a wrestler with AWA in Maryland and I
don't have a finisher yet so uh help me
out if you will gang and he's the
Chesapeake Crippler fat mystic Rick and
that Swiss wheelchair brother I'll tell
you you could do that anytime you see
what's this the name is fish a movie he
just doesn't have one yeah I think name
it any ideas weapons I don't know how
about you douse them in honey
Oh stick a sweet tooth killer oh yeah
put him in the sweet tooth dude then you
get out the jar honey right now no comes
out the music kid you don't see him pug
become our Undertaker does song hits and
it's fine Stefan it goes boys boys boys
and you can flying in short George
here's what I think
first of all excuse me Kelly arrows oh
yeah you need to get a you and another
fella need to come out of the closet and
get a gay tag team first ever right yes
and you hold him kind of bent over the
other guy jumps off the top rope hits
him right in the butt with his cry
and uh and just put that booty to sleep
you know it's called the bottom it's
called the Foggy Bottom
not the flying bottom so that's what I
think you do do you get them like a
confused have them bent over in the
middle of the Ring you go up the top
rope you fly off D first and hit them
right in the butt yeah and the guy
getting hit in the butts going no not
the butt no no yeah they come out what
song with the duo come out to open the
door baby it's cold outside maybe that
one was too slow so really can't stay so
baby it's cold outside
oh I know which one laughs to the left
how birthday is super short shorts ass
cheeks out the back well or you put them
in there and your other finished movies
called that dirty birthday bro yeah and
that's when you lay them on the ground
you put that you open their mouth up
they're unconscious you jump off the top
rope Weiner yeah it's called the broke
bag it's the Bill Cosby yeah when
they're already asleep you hit them with
that D bro good I think you got you got
some great ideas good start
yeah jumping off point why be a
heterosexual arrest or do that [ __ ] is
so 1800s and that WWE fan base I Love
You Man bro you come out as the first
gay wrestler yeah but you got to get
real tan like Razor Ramon and get all
oiled up and some short shorts they
always go crazy man crazy amount of oil
bro I'm talking even putting Vaseline on
your tongue everything yes y'all full
out full out just wet wet seal gotta go
yeah crazy style there I am in the
background of this
how did I get in there and who is this
Nancy Pelosi this is [ __ ]
unbelievable it has to stop man think
great think Razor Ramon but the touch of
West Hollywood just really really
outlandish yeah yeah gays are on yeah
the gay Ramon your fish is the power
bottom yeah and you just hit him with
that bottom dude you got them bent over
and you should hit them straight up de
frst and rum you're welcome
yeah you're welcome Tressa Piet Crippler
eaw may or w AE what is it called
you see a e W United Arab Emirates
fighting yeah quit fightin as a straight
male that shit's it's old-school man
yeah yeah be originally not gay just
figure it out yeah get gay in the ring
man yeah why be yeah Rachel Maddow I
think the ultimate warrior might suck
you off back in the day yeah whose
birthday is it what's this little it's a
great song unless the managers trying to
molest you all the time
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]